okay you're live
welcome everybody thank you for joining
us for our hands-on workshop today on
how to build web3 apps with hyperledger
firefly supernodes i really did have
everyone today we had a great webinar
last week talking about firefly and the
1.0 launch and there was a brief demo at
the end of it but i think there was a
lot of desire
to go deeper on some things and to
really get more hands-on so today is
today's going to be hands-on
and i'm really looking forward to it um
before we get in just uh uh
here's the agenda of the things that
we're going to be going over today i'm
going to cover a couple housekeeping
items uh i have a few slides to kind of
set the context for the workshop as well
as you know introducing firefly
uh the bulk of this time will be
the hands-on workshop will actually be
in a terminal and in a web browser using
firefly and doing blockchain stuff so
it's going to be really exciting we're
going to leave about 20 minutes at the
end for some road map discussion and q a
but again the the bulk of it is going to
be the workshop the whole session will
be an hour and a half so that's the
agenda
on to some housekeeping items please
note that this workshop is being
recorded
this workshop must abide by hyperledger
code of conduct and the antitrust policy
if you're not familiar with those you
can find them both on the hyperledger
foundation wiki
or
i guess you can't really click the link
there but my slides are linked to them
um a couple other housekeeping notes
there are a lot of us in this zoom which
is awesome i'm i'm happy to see such a
great turnout
um please keep your mic muted if you're
not speaking right now i'm the only one
that's speaking so uh if you're not me
please please go ahead and go on mute
just to cut down on background noise um
please please prefer chat as the first
resort for asking and getting questions
answered and again uh we would prefer
using the discord chat
as david was mentioning earlier the the
discord chat in the hyperledger discord
server under the firefly section there's
a dedicated firefly workshop uh channel
that we just created this morning so go
in there some of the other maintainers
are monitoring that and i will be happy
to to answer questions as we go along um
if you'd like to speak during the the
workshop that's okay i would love to
keep this interactive but just please go
ahead and raise your hand and wait to be
called on again there's a lot of us in
here and this will just kind of help us
keep it organized and keep on time i'm
happy to take some questions as we go
but there's a lot to cover and i'd
really like to keep us on track and on
time
so that's that's it for housekeeping
items thanks for bearing with me while
we go through that let's talk about what
we're going to do in the workshop today
so um we're going to use some some
pretty cool tools here today um you may
be familiar with heart hat already hard
hat is a pretty common tool for doing
ethereum development testing contract
deployment and that sort of stuff so
we're going to use hard hat and we're
going to compile a custom smart contract
we're going to deploy it to a blockchain
node running on our machines
and we're going to use we're going to
use that contract with firefly
and uh what we're what we're going to be
doing today is i'll get again i'll have
a slide on you know the end result and
goal of the
workshop in just a minute but the other
awesome tool that we're going to be
using is hyperledger firefly that's
probably what most people are here to
learn about today
hyperledger firefly if you have are not
familiar with it or didn't get a chance
to watch our webinar last week
we described firefly as the first open
source super node which is a complete
stack for
developers to build and scale
blockchain web3 applications
so
what is the value of firefly where does
it fit in the in the blockchain
ecosystem well it's not a blockchain
itself it's not a dlt uh it sits a layer
above that but but firefly the value to
a developer i'm assuming that most of us
are developers in in this room and so
kind of looking at things through that
lens the value to the developer is that
it takes care of this whole stack of
things that a developer needs to build
um you can see on you know on the left
we have this diagram of like okay at the
bottom we have
our our blockchain
and our smart contract and that's kind
of like
oftentimes when we're building a web 3
app that's what we think of first we go
to okay what's the what's the logic that
goes on chain what's the smart contract
look like and then all the way at the
top we have you know our business
application you know our web ui
our our user portal or maybe uh um
you know some sort of uh business uh
back office system that needs to be
integrated there but like how how do you
connect all of the things uh in the
middle of that there's there's once you
start getting into building an
enterprise web 3 application you realize
that there's a lot of plumbing and uh a
lot of you know electrical work and all
these things that are that are not very
fun things to develop that you still
need in order to actually build out an
entire enterprise grade web 3
application so that's that's the gap
that firefly fills
it's a platform it's a common foundation
to build enterprise web3 apps
so what types of things does it have in
it
it's got a lot uh if we if we kind of
break it down into to three main groups
though you've got apps you've got flows
and you've got digital assets and we'll
actually walk through a bunch of these
use cases in a little bit kind of
breaking them down into into these three
groups
so at the center you've got the firefly
core the firefly core is an
orchestration engine
and it's coordinating things that are
happening on the blockchain things that
are happening off chain uh it provides a
really easy to use rest api for for
developers to to access all these
functionalities it provides an event
delivery mechanism over web sockets
some of the other really cool things
about it is that it's it's a it's a
micro service architecture and it's very
pluggable so
uh there are specific implementations
that we'll talk about you know the
things that we're going to be running on
our machine later but you know if you
want to use a different database for
instance or if you want to use an
entirely different blockchain those are
plugins into firefly and so so firefly
is very modular it can adapt to meet uh
specific needs for specific business
cases and uh it's it's a it's a really
cool architecture
so i'm not going to spend a ton of time
on you know what firefly is and all the
value that it brings
um there was a great webinar on that
last week i hope that as we use it
you'll start to see the value and some
of the power behind it and the really
cool features but i just wanted to paint
a little bit of a picture before we jump
in here
okay so what are we going to build today
today my goal is that you walk away from
this workshop having all the pieces that
you need and the understanding to go
build a web3 app with its own token
economy powered by firefly
so how are we going to do that now we're
going to use hardhat we're going to
compile and deploy a custom erc20
contract
we're going to use the firefly sandbox
to walk through
using fireflies apis in a very
approachable user-friendly manner uh
which will provide us sample code
snippets that we can look at to see okay
how would we go build this feature into
our back end into our application that
we're going to build uh in the future so
so you know at the end of today
you you won't have a a full end-to-end
working application uh but you should
have all the knowledge and all the
pieces that you need to go build that
and uh would love to just you know see
the creativity that people uh and come
up with and the ideas that this will
spark as people start to see all the
different things that they can do with
firefly and an understanding of how all
the pieces fit together
so uh the things that we're gonna be
doing in the sandbox we're going to
create uh an api we're going to look at
the swagger ui that's generated for our
smart contract we're going to mint and
transfer tokens from the swagger ui
we're going to create a token pool to
let firefly index all of the
erc related transactions uh we're going
to send broadcasts and private messages
and kind of look at all of the the three
main groups of features in firefly uh
and throughout all that we're going to
be using the firefly explorer to inspect
and kind of see what's going on inside
firefly as we're doing these things
the tools that we're going to use again
so we're going to be using hard hat the
other tool that we're going to be
running on our machines is the firefly
cli i'll walk you through how to set
that up in just a minute
firefly cli is a tool that will set up a
local firefly development environment on
your machine it uses docker compose to
do this that's why docker is one of the
prereqs and it gives you all the
components of what we describe as a
super node right on your laptop
um so
what what goes into a super node here so
what we're going to be running when we
run the firefly cli and it starts up a
development stack is uh so we're going
uh you'll hear me talk about uh
different members of the firefly network
so you can think of different members as
perhaps different organizations or
different companies remember this is the
context here is building enterprise web
3 apps so
you may have different businesses that
need to transfer data transfer tokens
perform business transactions backed by
blockchain so that's what each of the
members are going to be in our firefly
network that we're going to stand up or
our firefly stack each of those members
has their own supernode and so inside
the supernode you have a firefly core
over here
uh each each firefly core is connected
to a database data exchange blockchain
connector tokens connector so on and so
forth uh there is
for to keep things simple and and as
lightweight as possible there's one
blockchain node that will run on your
machine
and uh both
uh both super nodes will end up actually
just sharing that same blockchain node
so as we're going through we're going to
be using firefly cores api we're gonna
be using the web ui the firefly explorer
to look at what's going on inside there
that that web ui is actually hosted by
the the firefly core
we're also going to be looking at the
firefly sandbox you can think of sandbox
as an application that sits outside the
super node it's it's an example of
an end user application that is written
to use fireflies api so so it's not part
of the super node but it's
we ship it with the firefly cli because
it's an awesome tool to learn about
firefly and try it out all in a web
browser
it also it will also provide code
snippets of you know how to use um
you know how to build these functions in
the back end okay so um before we jump
in um
i'm just going to check on chat here it
looks like there's there's some a few
questions that have been going on here
um any
any big questions that
any of the other firefly folks that are
online think i should address before we
hop into actually getting hands-on
okay
i'm going to i'm going to share my full
screen now
give me just a second to do that
all right here we go
so here's our workshop guide
this is the the github gist that i
linked to earlier um hopefully the the
font size is readable for everyone
kevin does it does it look like it's
coming through okay to you um yeah okay
that's great uh if i need to if i need
to adjust font size or anything please
just let me know i'm happy to zoom in on
stuff uh hopefully the screen size
should be good though
okay so uh hopefully you've had a chance
to go through the
before the workshop section and make
sure you have docker uh the firefly cli
will also use
openssl uh we'll also need node.js
installed hard hat uses node.js and so
that's that's why we need that as well
so
increase font size got it
good
yeah okay
all right so uh what we're going to do
first is
i want to get the
the environment created and get a
blockchain node running on my machine so
we're going to use the firefly cli to do
that
um we're i'm basically going to walk you
through the getting started guide so if
if we pop over to
the the firefly docs this is this is the
getting started experience for for folks
who are coming new to the project and
walks you through installing the cli
starting an environment and using the
sandbox i'm going to be walking you
through that today so we're going to
start with installing the firefly cli
which is the the first step there
okay so if you happen to be a go
developer and you have go set up on your
machine you can you can just go install
the firefly cli if not that's okay if
you don't want to worry about setting up
a go dev environment that's not a
requirement
in that case we can go to
the releases page um so we'll see you
know go to download the package for your
os go to the latest release page on
github and we will just download uh the
appropriate binary for our machine so
i'm running on
an m1 mac here so i'm going to download
the darwin x86 sorry arm 64. they both
have a 64 in them so i oftentimes get
them confused at first glance
okay i'm going to download that
and
you know make sure you download the one
that's appropriate for your system
if you are running on windows
you should be able to use the
the linux binaries in
windows subsystem for linux 2 and if you
have docker set up to use wsl 2 as well
uh that that configuration should work
for you
okay uh i'm just gonna there's a handy
command here basically
basically we just need to unzip this
thing and put it somewhere on our
machine that we can call it i've got a
command here that i can copy and paste
to put it in my bin directory so i'm
just going to do that here i'll make my
font a little bigger in my terminal
[Music]
it's going to ask me for my password
because that's a
directory and
type it correctly
okay there we go
so now that we've got i have the firefly
cli binary installed in my bin directory
so i should be able to
run uh
ff version
and you know what i have a version
compiled from source hang on let me let
me get rid of that um
sorry for that
okay so if i run ff version
now my mac is going to say hey you
didn't pay apple a whole bunch of money
to sign this so i'm not gonna run it um
that's okay we can we can deal with this
you just hit okay
um it's gonna kill it that's fine um
you'll go to system preferences
go up to security and privacy
and then so it'll say ff was blocked
because it's not from an identified
developer we'll allow that that's fine
the next time we run ff version it'll
say hey are you really sure you want to
run this yes okay
and then there we go okay so i'm running
0.0.48 so that's that's the latest
release that's out there
and uh hopefully
you've been able to to get that and run
that on your machine as well
okay let's go back to our guide and see
where we're at next so we've got the
firefly cli installed
now we're going to create an environment
so this is kind of step two in the
firefly getting started guide is you
know set up a dev environment um
i'm going to use a slightly different
command than what's in the firefly docs
because a i want to use erc20 and
the default is erc 1155
and then i also want to customize the
names of the organizations so so this
command is going to initialize a new
stack it's going to call it workshop
it's going to
uh it's going to create a network of
three members that way we can demo uh
both public and private transactions and
i'm going to use the erc20 erc721 token
connector and then the prompt names
command here is uh is going to
just let me type in
my own names for all the the
organizations and and nodes um before we
before we create it i just want to
highlight real quick all all the
different so if if you want
to see all the different things the
firefly seal i can do you can run ff
help
uh it will print out here's all the
commands that the firefly cli can do if
you want to know hey what are the
different things i can customize in a
firefly stack when i create it you can
run ff init
help
and here's the the full list of options
so you can customize which blockchain it
uses
if i add a dash b
space fabric it will use a fabric block
chain we're not going to demo that today
we're going to focus on erc20 on an
ethereum node but
but you can do that you can have it use
postgres instead of
the built-in sqlite database you can
enable prometheus metrics there's a
bunch of different options that you can
set here
okay so
uh we are going to i'm going to just
copy this command here
oops
and i'm going to run this and for for
clarity of the workshop and the demo i'm
going to name my
uh my
organizations and nodes red
green and blue and i have three
different themed chrome browsers that
should match those colors if i get the
order right here
um and so you can name them whatever you
want the name here is not important um
if you don't use prompt names then it
will just go with default names of org0
or one et cetera so i'm gonna call this
one red and then i'm going to name the
node for this one red node
and i'm going to call this one
green
and green node
blue
and blue node
this will just visually help
give a little bit of an indicator of
when we're looking at the three
different browsers
which perspective we're looking at the
network from
okay great so we have
uh initialized the stack we're not
running it yet but let's go ahead and do
that
um before we run it just wanted to call
out uh if you are running on a machine
like mine on a mac that actually runs
docker containers inside of vm uh we'll
want to make sure we have enough ram
allocated to to run this because it's
going it will start up quite a few
docker containers
um
if if you need to double check that you
can go up here to
the uh the docker desktop and click on
dashboard
uh we can hit the little gear icon here
and then click on resources
i recommend at least a gigabyte of ram
per member so i'm using three members
here uh i usually have
i usually give my docker vm like seven
or eight gigs of ram and uh that tends
to be great
so just wanted to point that out um if
you don't have enough ram unfortunately
some of the
uh
yep um
unfortunately some of the processes
struggle a little bit with with not
having enough ram
okay
so now we're going to run ff start
and then we're going to tell it to start
the workshop
all right so we'll let this go for a
little bit it's going to pull some
docker containers uh it's going to
um going to going to initialize our
blockchain node and start everything up
i'm going to pause and uh and kind of
catch my breath here a little bit um
i i also got feedback that i may need to
slow down a little bit because folks are
trying to follow along so i apologize if
i'm going through this too quickly um
there's
there's a lot of exciting stuff i want
to share but um
i'm just just checking out chat here
okay uh any any
before we hop over to hard hat and start
looking at the contract um
anything that i can help clarify
or or any any questions that we want to
address before we move on to kind of the
next phase here in the guide
so i think the questions nico i can just
see as we've been tracking in the in the
chats
i i think we've got people following
along which is fantastic
and as you're going um and people have
been just really focused on making sure
they've got what they need on their
machine
i wonder if a couple of people maybe on
the chats could just know if they if
they got there successfully you just get
a confirmation from a couple of people
that they've they've got there
um
to this point and whether we need a
couple of minutes
to
um
just allow people to catch up here
sure yeah yeah anyone
has anyone been able to get to this
point where they've been able to start a
stack on their machine along with me
here
i'm starting my machine it's in
initialization
awesome okay
i
it may take a little bit longer than
what it did on my machine i probably had
a lot of the docker images already so
okay yeah somebody had something
listening on yeah so
there are quite a few ports that are
exported um that's probably something i
should have noted as well
uh there's quite a few ports that the
docker compose file exports and so
uh
it it should
if there is a port collision the firefly
cli should tell you which port it tried
to grab and found something else
listening on already
okay so it sounds like uh sounds like
some folks are
are tracking along or or are very close
to getting a stack started up so that so
that's great
um
and you've got a recent
install of the apple operating system
um it may have enabled a
system for sharing an app yes
yes
okay
yeah let me um thank you for that
reminder that was
uh a while ago i forgot about that okay
so
in the
thanks apple for this uh in the latest
version of mac os uh there is a new
feature that apple added
and uh it it it happens to listen on
port 5000. uh if you want to disable
that i'll walk you through that right
now
it is it's an airplay receiver and so i
just go to system preferences i go to
sharing
and uh there is
a thing at the bottom here called
airplay receiver
this will listen on the port that the
firefly core wants to allocate to itself
so if you just uncheck this and then try
to run ffstart that should solve that
problem if you're running on a mac and
running into the port collision there
that was a good call out peter and thank
you i had forgotten about that
okay
let's go back to our guide here
all right so we've run we have ran
start workshop
now we're going to shifters and look at
our contracts that we're going to deploy
so
so what have we done so far we've set up
a
firefly development environment on our
machine we have a blockchain node
running we haven't done anything with it
we will go look at it in a little bit
but we're going to kind of shift gears
now and then
go look at hard hat which is a different
tool
to
this is a tool that ethereum developers
are probably familiar with and so we're
going to look at you know how do we take
an existing workflow that people are
probably familiar with or at least some
of the concepts they're familiar with
and and use that with firefly so
[Music]
firefly has
a
uh this concept of a tokens connector
and a tokens connector is a a bridge i'm
sorry it's not a it's not not a bridge
it's a it's a a component that sits in
between the firefly core
and the
uh
and and the the blockchain node itself
and it is written in such a way that it
knows about what type of contract that
it's supposed to be working with so
uh in the firefly hyperledger github
repos there are two different reference
implementations of what a token
connector might look like
if you are building your own
uh your own smart contract your own
token implementation and you want to run
on firefly we highly recommend you you
should build a token connector that is
knowledgeable about your specific
contract but there is a reference
implementation provided for erc 20 and
721 which we're going to be looking at
today
so we're going to clone that github repo
hop back over to my terminal
i'm going to go ahead and
just open a new tab in my terminal here
and then
i'm going to go to
my code directory and i have a workshop
directory in there there's nothing in
here right now so i'm just going to
clone this repo here you can clone it
anywhere you want on your computer
and then if we look at the guide again
it says cd into that directory and then
inside there there's a solidity
directory so
we just cloned the source for the whole
the whole token connector we're not
going to run the whole token connector
because we're actually already running
it in our docker environment but what we
need is the solidity files that are in
there so if we look at this directory it
has some some files in it if we look at
contracts directory there are some
solidity files in there um so i'm just
going to actually open up my ide real
quick and
show you what is in there
that's probably a little too big there
we go
so we look at contracts we see there's
this is the contract that we're going to
deploy it's erc20 with data uh this
extends the open zeppelin erc20 contract
i haven't installed dependencies which
is why we're getting all the red
underlines here uh we'll solve that in
just a minute
um and so
yeah so this this extends
open zeppelin and uh implements erc20
and firefly has this concept of being
able to associate data with transfer so
that's that's what uh erc20 with data is
all about uh there's also a contract
provider for 721
we don't have time to look at that as
well today we'd love to do a separate
talk on nfts uh but
you should be able to take everything
that we have talked about here today and
with you know some some minor changes
also you could do the same with 721 if
you wanted to but we're gonna focus on
erc20 today
okay
um so i'm gonna hop back over to my
terminal and
actually i'm gonna go back to the guide
and it says now run npm install so
that's what we're gonna do next so again
i'm in the i just cloned the repo i cd
into it i'm in the solidity directory
and i'm an npm install this will install
hard hat it will install the open
zeppelin
contract dependencies and everything
that we need to be able to compile our
contract
we'll give that a second
okay great so we've got our dependencies
installed
uh we'll pause to kind of make sure
people are keeping up here
any uh
any any questions or comments that i can
uh address while we're kind of you know
letting people get get the repo set up
get things installed
another sort of public announcement if
you haven't seen it on discord if you
have a permissions error trying to get
clone
um
make sure you're using the
https link
to clone the repo not the ssh link
apologies for that um i would have
thought ssh should have worked for
everyone so so if so that would look
like um
git clone and instead of
instead of git at github.com do https
colon slash
github.com
hyperledger firefly and i can just drop
this in chat as well so everyone has
this here
should be https
probably
okay
hopefully everyone can clone that repo
run npm install and get the dependencies
installed again we're working in the
solidity directory inside there
um
uh there's a question is it possible to
use rust rather than solidity on the dev
side uh i i you know as long as you can
compile and deploy an ethereum smart
contract onto the chain um you're
welcome to use whatever tooling chain or
or language you would like
um the
uh the the end goal here is to get a
smart contract on chain so that's uh
hard hat
and solidity are the the
tools of choice here for today but uh
you know as long as you can get an
ethereum contract deployed to the
blockchain node you're running locally
you're welcome to use whatever tooling
you want uh use truffle or or
any other tools that are
common ethereum smart contract
development tools
okay uh
now we're gonna run it so
sorry we're gonna compile and deploy it
so if we look in
just just so you can see what's going on
here
um inside the solidity directory there
is a scripts directory and there's a
deploy script here this is we're going
to run this script and
this will compile and deploy our smart
contract and it will print out the the
addresses that it has
deployed the contracts to at the end i
see someone has raised their hand yeah
go ahead
uh hi um
does the firefly super node runs then
ethereum node that are going to deploy
to or ethereum like node
yes it does yeah so um great great
question and
i can just show you real quick what
after we ran our stack um i could run
docker ps
and we can see
all the things that we have running here
so
sorry some of my zoom windows are in the
way a little bit but we've got
we have
three firefly cores we have three token
connectors three block chain connectors
uh and then right here this is our go
ethereum blockchain node that's running
on our machine and so
uh internally it's listening on uh eight
five four
five yeah
so i'm going to
i'm going to talk directly to that node
uh
uh to deploy and uh work with my
contract or i'm going to use another
interface of firefly yep yeah so so
we're going to have so great great
question and let me show you what's
going to go on here behind the scenes
when we run this deploy script it's
going to use the
uh there's a hardhatconfig.ts and this
is an important detail so great question
thank you
um i i've already put in this repo a
configuration to use the firefly network
that's running locally on your machine
and so here we've configured a network
called firefly and we've told it this is
the url the blockchain node and this is
what hard hat will talk to when it goes
to deploy this contract so hopefully
that clarifies there
yeah thank you
yep yep
um did i see someone else with their
hand up they had a question
okay maybe not
okay so yeah it's a great question about
you know how does the deployment work so
uh that you know we have a blockchain
node running here that's where we're
gonna deploy to and this script is
what's actually gonna do it so to run
this we can just go back to our guide
and run
npx hard hat
run script deploy.ts
and so we'll make sure we do that in the
solidity directory we'll just run that
command
this will compile our contract
uh we may see a couple of warnings um
that's okay
i am going to go look at those later
though and see if we can clean that up
so that compiled it and it deployed it
and so we can see here at the output we
can see our erc20 contract was deployed
to this ethereum address you can see our
erc 721 contract was deployed to this
ethereum address
so this is great we have a contract on
chain and now we can start to use this
with firefly uh i'm gonna i'm gonna
take another moment to pause here uh
because we're about to shift gears now
and go start looking at actually using
firefly with this contract so i want to
make sure that you know if if people are
following along and trying to keep up we
get at least to this point where we have
the contract on chain because that's
that's a kind of a big milestone in the
workshop is making sure we get our
contract actually deployed so i'll just
i'll just kind of pause for a minute uh
folks have a couple questions i can i
can take a minute to answer those as we
go here
uh somebody asked for the link to the
gist yep
um yeah sorry let me send that to
everyone here just in case
okay
um yes
mustafa you got your hand up go ahead
um
so the connector uh the
the coin connector
uh
what does that
what's this rule here does it like
connect ethereum
contract yeah i'm glad that
yes yeah i'm glad you asked um we have
not actually used the token connector
yet but that's going to be one of the
the really cool parts of the workshop
here in just a few minutes okay thank
you
okay yes there uh we are recording this
and uh the recording will be made
available afterward as well
all right so uh i'm conscious of time
here and i want to make sure that we we
get to
to look at some of these really cool
features of firefly so we're gonna we're
gonna jump into
uh the firefly sandbox now so uh there
is a guide in the docks on uh this is
kind of you know step three of the the
getting started experience in firefly
which is using the sandbox and there's a
video walkthrough
from the webinar last week
a little bit of a description of what
the sandbox is uh yeah again it's an end
user it's written as an end user
application so it sits outside the super
node it uses fireflies api and it's kind
of broken up into these three columns
here
i'm going to actually open it up
there is there is a link here right in
the docs that should open up the ui for
the first member
i'm going to try to
keep things straight by using these
color themed
chrome browsers remember when i set up
my network i named them red green and
blue
and so i'm going to open up the sandbox
for the first node here so this is what
the sandbox looks like
it is uh kind of broken up into three
columns
and
on the left here we have a form that we
can fill out that will
prepare requests for us in the middle we
have an example of some server code that
will
uh you can you can think of this as like
if i'm building a back-end application
that is designed to use firefly here's
an example of some code that i can go
take and put right in my application
this uses the firefly sdk this is this
is node.js typescript code here uh using
our node.js sdk
uh there is sdk support coming for more
languages in the future but uh
right now we've got node.js
and uh so that's what that's what this
firefly variable is here it represents
an imported node.js sdk
um we're going to start on the contracts
panel so there's three different panels
here messaging tokens and contracts
we're going to start with our custom
contract that we deployed
and so so you can imagine a use case
where you know i'm building an app that
has a
an erc20 token economy built into it
but it's a custom contract it has extra
features it has things that are are not
in the the standard erc20 interface and
i want to use firefly to interact with
those features
so so that's what we're going to show
first
uh so
uh just a couple of concepts here that i
want to go over so uh we have in in
firefly a thing called a contract
interface so first of all there's some
some helpful hints here on on how to
deploy a contract we've already done
that because we walked through that with
hardhat
um
i want to just take a brief moment and
talk about a con
contract interfaces and contract apis
because these are some some building
blocks of really powerful features
inside firefly so
in the ethereum world we have uh
ethereum abi format which describes the
inputs and the outputs and events and
all the type information
in a smart contract and all the
functions that it has
and this is a great way to to just
inform a system about the shape of a
smart contract
firefly is is multi-chain multi-protocol
and so so it works with
ethereum but it also works with fabric
and it could also be extended to work
with other types of blockchains so we
wanted a way to be able to describe a
smart contract in for any blockchain so
that's what the firefly interface format
is all about it is a way to describe a
contract in a blockchain agnostic format
yet still encapsulating blockchain
specific important information like the
type for instance for ethereum you'll
see
inside an ffi it still embeds the the
specific evm type that a variable will
be treated as in the
evm um
and so so this also has the advantage of
now we have a way to define an interface
that can describe for instance a fabric
chain code and it doesn't matter what
language the the particular chain code
is implemented in
it we have a way that we can talk about
smart contracts in uh in a way that's
blockchain agnostic so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna tell firefly about uh
the shape of our
our erc20 contract that we've just
deployed so firefly doesn't know
anything about it right now it's just on
the blockchain but firefly doesn't know
where it is or anything about it
um
because we already because we're using
an ethereum contract and we already have
an api firefly also has a convenience
function to convert that ethereum abi
into an ffi to or firefly interface and
that saves me as a developer a bunch of
time typing out a bunch of handcrafted
json which is probably going to be
error-prone
so what we're going to do is we're going
to switch this toggle to api json and
we're going to upload that we're going
to just paste in the api here from our
contract so you can find that and if i
go back over to my ide
um i'll i'll tell you where you can find
it and then it's also in the gist so so
you don't have to go digging for it but
just just for for your knowledge it's
going to be under artifacts it's going
to be in build info and it's going to be
in this big long ugly json document um
it's in here i promise
there's a bunch of other stuff in here
though so to save time from sorting
through that i've actually already
copied that out and i have put it in the
guide here
this is for convenience i've also
included a copy here um so you can
you know select this whole thing
and again this is just the ethereum api
for that contract that we have compiled
and we're going to copy this
[Music]
sorry i'm going to go back to my red
browser from my red member here and i'm
just going to paste this whole thing
into this box here
okay
i need to give it a name and a version
so uh within
firefly uh just about everything is is
encapsulated in a namespace and so
a namespace is just a way to to group
data and messages and
and definitions of things so within a
namespace
the name and the version of a contract
interface needs to be unique because
that is going to refer to a specific
smart contract or a specific version of
a smart contract
so i'll just call it erc20 with data you
can name it whatever you want um
there are some some
conventions that it needs to conform to
but you don't have to name it the same
thing that i am here that's fine and i'm
just going to say that this is version
1.0 now i'm going to go over here and on
the on the server code i'm going to hit
run so this is what i'm basically doing
is i'm telling the sandbox backend
server make a request to fireflies api
to broadcast this contract definition
and what do i mean by broadcast well so
um
a variety of things just happened there
we see that there was a transaction that
was submitted um so so actually sorry
first immediately we see it we got a 202
accepted and then we got an id back
that's a message id that we can look up
in firefly to see what what happened
with that message later and we can we
can see
what the results of that request was so
so firefly uses an asynchronous
programming model so when you when you
make a request oftentimes you get an id
back and you can use that id to look it
up later you can also
uh set up
an a websocket listener to to listen for
events uh if you don't want to and
that's actually the encourage model so
rather than polling for status your
application can receive updated status
in real time
okay
[Music]
so over here on the right side we do the
sandbox does have a websocket set up and
it's listening for events coming from
firefly and we can see we got uh there
was a transaction that was submitted we
received a blockchain event uh there was
a contract interface that was confirmed
and the message that was used to
broadcast that was confirmed so uh what
happened there under the covers
uh let's go to to answer that question
let's go take a look at the
firefly explorer and see what happened
in firefly now real quick
all right so i'm just going to open a
new tab
this is if you're curious how i got here
if you go back and look at where you
started up your firefly stack there were
some urls that got printed out here and
so i'm just looking at uh web ui for
member xero and this is the this is the
link right here that i that i've just
opened in my red browser so uh this is
the firefly explorer this is
a kind of a view into the system a view
into the both my node and
my node's perspective of the network so
we can see a network map we can see our
red blue and green members here and each
of their nodes
we can see some information about my
node
that was
you know all the plugins that i'm
currently using and we can see there's a
little bit of activity here now so there
was a batch pin
uh there was a message confirmed
contract interface confirmed
and so so what is a batch pin you might
be wondering well um firefly will will
take you know if there's a bunch of
requests coming in all at once it will
batch them together for efficiency it
will hash them and then it will pin data
to the blockchain hence the name
batchpin
and so uh so so what's happened here is
when we broadcasted this contract
interface
uh it was sent to there was a message
that was sent to all the other members
so the we can actually go look at
the let's go look at the green node here
as well and open up its firefly explorer
we can see that it has some some of the
same things
the transaction wasn't submitted from
this node but we see we have the same
events over here contract interface
confirmed
message confirmed blockchain event
received
so
what happened is when i broadcasted that
it firefly took the the payload of that
json document it uh it hashed the
payload
it
pinned the hash of that to the
blockchain and it put the actual json
payload on ipfs
and then
all the other members
are listening for blockchain events that
are happening on the firefly batch pin
contract they all saw the event oh hey
something was pinned to the blockchain
what is that let me go get the the data
payload that's associated with this oh
it's a it's a contract interface great
let me store that in my database now now
i'm aware of this contract interface
that was just declared so if we go to
any of the members now we should be able
to look at
the blockchain section here in the
dashboard
and we see there was a batch pin event
but we can also go here and we can look
at interfaces and we see that there is
this interface that's been
defined here
that's cool not very useful yet we'll
get to where where it's going to be
really useful in just a second i just
kind of wanted to describe
uh something you know kind of what's
going on behind the scenes when we're
doing all these things
okay uh let's go back to our red members
sandbox here
and now what we want to do is we want to
actually use this thing so right now
we've just told firefly about the shape
of it and that's it um
and so next i'm going to go to uh to
register a contract api so what this is
going to do is it's going to build
an http api and it's going to build a
swagger ui for us to work with all the
functions on here
um i'm also conscious of the time i
realized that i want to leave time for
it for discussion at the end and we are
rapidly running out of time so i'm going
to try to speed things up a little bit i
hope you can follow along uh if if you
get lost in this part this will all be
recorded so hopefully you can kind of go
back and walk through some of these
things with me after the fact but
um there's a few more things that i want
to show here
okay so we're going to register a
contract api i need to give it a name uh
this name is going to be part of the url
path so it needs to be url safe
and so i'm just going to call it erc20
and we need to give it an address for
this we're gonna hop back over to where
we used hard hat and remember i told you
to to save these addresses uh we're
gonna copy the address for the erc20
contract and we're just gonna paste that
into this box right here
so this is going to tell firefly hey
that contract interface that i
broadcasted earlier i want you to
generate a rest api for me and when
somebody calls
uh http methods on it
i want you to send blockchain requests
to this address here so we're going to
broadcast that this also gets
broadcasted and pinned to the blockchain
the same way as our interface did
now
now that i've done that i can go here i
can hit refresh and then i can see that
i've created a contract api so let's go
take a look at that now we'll hit this
little pop out button and here is a
swagger ui
that has been dynamically generated by
firefly
that gives us a listing of all the
endpoints that we can now use to
interact with our contract
so uh let's do something with our
contract now uh this is you know kind of
the
the whole point of everything that we've
been building up to here uh so let's
let's mint some tokens first we don't
have any right now so let's uh we'll
we'll mint uh so in this uh in this case
we're gonna call the invoke uh mint with
data function uh or endpoint rather here
it is i'm gonna hit try it out
uh i need to fill out a couple things i
need to first tell it how many um let's
just do
we'll do a hundred
i can give it some data i don't actually
need to give it any data at the moment
so i'm going to do
i'm just going to put 0x00 here and then
i need to tell it who to send it to i'm
going to mint it to myself and then
we'll do some transfers to the other
members here in a second
to find out
you know what what's the red node's
ethereum address because that's an
important thing to know here
i'm going to go back to the firefly
explorer look under network and
organizations and i can see there's one
labeled your org here okay so this is me
i'm going to click here there is a
verifiers
section here and it has that has my
ethereum address i'm just going to hit
this button to copy it i'm going to go
back to my swagger ui and paste that
here
okay again if you're looking to figure
out you know what where did i get that i
went back to the firefly explorer i went
network organizations and i clicked on
and org here
okay
so that's that should be enough to mint
100 tokens we're going to run that we
get a 202 back
it's great
um let's let's go query this smart
contract and see you know do we actually
have a balance now
and so to do that we're going to scroll
down to
the query endpoint and we're going to
check uh balance of
and i'm just going to paste my
my ethereum address here run that
and we get 100. so that's cool um let's
check one of the other members and see
if they have any balance
just for the sake of the example uh
we'll copy the green members
address we'll paste it here
we would expect none and indeed we have
none okay so so only the red member has
a balance right now uh let's do a
transfer real quick
uh
so i'm going to go to let's see i'm
going to just scroll back up here i'll
collapse this
uh just save some space okay invoke
transfer is what we want to do
i'll hit try it out um let's send the
we'll send the the green member um
send them 10
and i'm going to paste the green
member's address there
run
we got a 202 so so that's you know the
the request was accepted we don't know
that it necessarily went through but we
can we can go back down here and then
check their balance again
so it was previously zero i'm just gonna
execute the same one and then now we've
got ten okay great so we've done a mint
we've done a transfer
uh we've done that through firefly's
custom smart contract support which
which is really cool so
you know we're working with an erc20
contract here um but but maybe again
maybe your contract has custom functions
on it that you want to be able to use
through firefly as well or or maybe
you're working with an entirely
different type of contract that's not an
erc or something like that um the
firefly is it's approachable it has
really easy to use apis but it also is
powerful and gives you full control of
using any smart contract with it
but um this was still quite a few steps
and uh there's there's still
you know if i want to build an app that
has a whole token economy there's still
a bunch of things that i need to
actually build a robust app uh for
example i'll just throw one out there
what if i want to see the whole
transaction history of everything that's
happened on this coin or
what are the wallets that have been
interacting with it or what are people's
current balances so
let's take a look at the firefly
explorer real quick there is a token
section here and it has a dashboard and
you'll notice there's nothing in here
we have we've been working with our
erc20
contract and through the the custom
contract support in firefly but
at this point uh there was a question
that was asked earlier what is the role
of the token connector and i haven't
answered that question yet and i'm about
to now this is where the token connector
comes into play we haven't actually told
firefly to to go you know index the
history of this contract uh listen for
events on it or or any of that stuff any
of the the
kind of all the plumbing and and
transactional history and things that
you need to actually build an enterprise
app with the token economy uh so that's
what we're going to do now so
that's kind of what uh this middle
column here is about in the sandbox is
using firefly's rich first-class token
support and tokens apis that are built
in
so first of all i'm going to create a
token pool i'm going to call it um i'm
going to call it
ffc for firefly coin
the the symbol is ffc that's what is
also in the contract um if you specify a
symbol here it needs to match
what's in the contract and and i'm going
to get the contract address so again to
get that i'm just going to go back to my
terminal
and copy
from the
from where we deployed this from hard
hat
and so so if we look in the the firefly
explorer um you know our tokens
dashboard is looking pretty sad right
now there's nothing there um but as soon
as i run this
we're gonna see a variety of things
happen so we created a token pool and
all of a sudden
uh
we told firefly about the address of the
contract and this now tells firefly to
start talking to its tokens connector
which is aware of how an erc20 works
so
so between the combination of
firefly and the token connector and the
blockchain uh it's going to build the
the transaction history and store that
in our database it's going to populate
the the firefly explorer and it's going
to give us a much richer view of what's
going on with our token contract so now
let's hop back over to the explorer
we'll just reload it and all of a sudden
we start to see this dashboard come
alive
we've got some token transfers that have
happened we have a history of a mint and
a transfer
we have a
uh you know we can see our account
balances here of you know this is the
original 100 that we minted and we
transferred 10 of it to the other member
and we can see our token pool here we
can we can click onto any of these
things and kind of drill down into them
to get more details about them so we can
see this is using the erc20 erc721
connector it's a fungible pool uh it has
18 decimal places
and we can see
you know the the contract address and
all this good stuff and so so all this
just became available to us because we
we told
uh we created this token pool and told
the
tokens connector that firefly is using
about this contract and it has has built
kind of this this rich dashboard for us
to use here now
this also opens up
the the firefly first class minting
transferring and burning apis as well so
we've already minted some we can see our
balance here is 90. but let's do some
transfers from here now we can do a
transfer right in the sandbox we don't
have to go into the swagger um we
the the cool thing is we don't even have
to actually go look up ethereum
addresses because the sandbox is now
it's aware of all of these things so i
believe we transferred some to green
before i'm going to transfer some to
blue now let's let's send another 10
over to blue and we'll hit run
okay and let's go take a look at the
blue members dashboard now we haven't
looked at that one so we're going to
open up firefly explorer on this one
and let's take a look at
the tokens section here
and now we can see yep our balances are
being updated
uh the the first member has 80 and both
of the other members have 10 now we can
see both transfers here
and again if we were transferring with
data we could also look up the actual
the blockchain event and see what that
data was that was attached to the
transfer as well so there's a lot of
information you can kind of dig into
here
um and then let's you know for the for
the sake of the completeness of the demo
let's let's burn some tokens too um
let's burn 10. i mostly wanted to show
this because i just think the the burn
icon is is the coolest one in the
dashboard here i refresh there's our
burn icon
it's just straight fire
okay and then let's just make sure our
our accounts have updated yep so we had
80 and we burned 10. so we've got 70
because we we've transferred 10 to each
member and then we burned 10. so our
account balances are continuing to
update there
so so hopefully you've been able to kind
of follow the journey here uh if not
actually doing it but you've been able
to follow along and it's made sense if
you know we've we've started with our
own erc20 contract that we compiled we
deployed it to the chain we told firefly
about it we we accessed it directly with
our swagger api
and then and then we we used fireflies
rich token support to uh to start
indexing the the complete history of the
token contract even before
we made firefly really aware of the fact
that this was an erc20 contract it was
able to go build that history even you
know back before uh we told it about
that
and um so so there's one other just
quick i i'll just real quick walk you
through the the last tab on the sandbox
and then and then we'll kind of wrap
things up and then leave some time for
for some discussion and q a at the end
here but i also just wanted to briefly
touch on the messaging tab uh because
this is this is kind of like the
uh we've talked a little bit about
messaging when we talked about
broadcasting
um but this is the the other
foundational building block in firefly
of building
enterprise web 3 apps is you know
sometimes i just need to get a piece of
data from from one organization to
another i want to use blockchain to do
that and sometimes i need that the data
itself to be public sometimes i need it
to be private
firefly supports a variety of different
combinations there so in the sandbox if
i just hit
expand send a broadcast message and i'm
sure we'll just send this is a message
uh we'll wait for the event to go
through that it's great now uh to see
messages i can look in
the off chain tab here and look under
messages i can see there was a broadcast
message
um
and here's the data that was associated
with that the data could be uh in this
case i just sent a string it could be a
json object uh it could be
a
a file it could be a binary attachment
that was referenced by id
and i'll demonstrate that in just a
second as well
just for the sake of the the
demonstration let's pop over to one of
the other members
we'll look at their
sorry we'll go to off chain look at
messages we should be able to see that
same exact yep this is a message here we
go so so that went to everyone
we can look at the blue member as well
look at their messages
okay this is a message great
let's do a let's
let's do a slightly different scenario
here let's send a private message uh in
this case
uh as a hypothetical example i have a
file that i need to send from one member
to another and so i'm gonna go to the
the file attachment uh toggle here i'm
gonna choose a file uh on my desktop i
have a really cool picture uh it's it's
the firefly logo
it's a png
uh it's um
you know it's not too big it's 20k but
20k is still a lot to store on chain uh
so what we're going to do is uh this
file will actually get stored in ipfs
and then we're going to send a
basically it will send the sorry this is
a private message so it is not stored in
ipfs this uses fireflies data exchange
i'm sorry for the i misspoke there
briefly
this will use fireflies data exchange to
directly transfer this file from one
member to another
and it will still hash and pin the the
file the payload of it to the blockchain
so that i as the red member can attest
that yes i actually had this data
and i
i can prove that i had this data on this
date
so we're going to send it from red to
we'll send it to blue and then i'll hit
run
that will upload the file it will send
the private message and so we should be
able to go over to the
the blue members dashboard now and let's
look at the data tab here and here we
can see we received this data it's about
20k
and i can just click right here and i
can download that thing i can open it up
and there's my image that i just sent
that's great
just to prove that it was indeed a
private transfer let's go to the green
member who should have been completely
in the dark about the contents of that
message that was sent
and we will jump over to
the
the data tab here sorry and we can see
that the last thing that it has was this
is a message it does not have the
the private data that was sent from the
the red member to the blue member
okay so so hopefully you get an idea of
you know the things that you can do in
the sandbox uh kind of these these
the three what i would describe is the
three pillars of firefly features
messaging tokens and smart contracts
and uh there's a lot that you can do
with them they give you the very
powerful building blocks to to build
enterprise grade web 3 applications
and
hopefully this gives you you know enough
of a starting point that okay i can i
can go from
using you know command line tooling and
and building my own contract i can i
know how to deploy it to a chain i know
how to
how to use firefly with that contract i
know how to do tokens transactions
and and i know how to send messages now
between applications these are some of
the building blocks that you need to
build a web 3 app so hopefully this has
given you enough of a starting point
that now
you got the creative juices flowing and
you know you're thinking of all the
different things that can be built with
these functionalities um just real quick
uh i would like to
before we jump into open discussion at
the end um i i i never like to to let a
good opportunity go to waste to uh to
invite people to to join in the firefly
community uh this is an open source
community and and it's in my opinion a
very open open source community uh we
would love for you to join us on discord
if you're not already in there chatting
in in the channel
for the workshop there's
please come over and join us we'd love
to continue the dialogue um
myself and a bunch of the other
maintainers are are in there on a daily
basis chatting with folks answering
questions about firefly
and uh and it's also a great place to
give for
for us to receive feedback too of like
hey i tried this thing it didn't work oh
well that's not expected you know um
let's let's take a look at that together
also uh you're the source it's all open
source it's on github go check out the
source uh we would love uh if you have
ideas of of things that you you want to
build on firefly or new plugins or
feature enhancements um
we would welcome contributions to the
project so
come come chat with us come check out
the source and we'll just love for for
more and more people to get involved in
this project because i think it's really
exciting and i think it has a lot of
potential
so
thank you all for for listening um i
think at this point we are going to kind
of transition now into uh
peter
broadhurst one of the other maintainers
on the project wanted to talk a little
bit about kind of future road map and
where where is the project going from
here because i'm sure a lot of people
are really curious about that and then
we will open it up for uh for just open
discussion after that if people have
questions we can discuss you know
whatever topics that people want to talk
about so i think we have about 24
minutes left so i will go ahead and turn
it over at this point to peter uh but
thank you all very much for following
along in the workshop today i really
appreciate it
thank you so much nico um i'm just gonna
start showing my screen here
um so before we go
into roadmap i'm just gonna recap a
little bit um
i hope everyone's enjoyed getting your
hands on firefly no matter how fast food
you got
um during the session today
the discord is there
keep going with us
keep chatting with us um
i will be great for you to make sure you
you get to the point that you've got
that sandbox there
so the journey that we went through was
use the cli which is a developer tool
just to get it running on your laptop it
gets all the components running it gets
the blockchain running it gets firefly
core running it gets all the connectors
for tokens
it's not a production deployment tool so
production deployment
how does that work kubernetes hell and
devops tooling um i would love to have
that conversation on on discord but that
tool gets you that environment running
on your laptop you then have the firefly
explorer ui
which is a lot like a block uh block
explorer will be for just the blockchain
layer
this is the tool that lets you see
what's going on in firefly and all the
layers the block chain and then all of
the off chain pipes and the tokens and
everything as well and then this
absolutely fantastic tool which you saw
um uh nico demonstrating and hats off to
the community members that built less
over the last few weeks um it just lets
you experiment with all the different
things that powerful i can do so i hope
you get to the point you've got all
those tools there and you can really
experiment
um i just want to take a little bit of a
step back
at this point and kind of talk about
what firefly does today
before we talk about roadmap let's just
talk about what you know
you install um the the
the v1 or firefly what have you got
so it's what do we mean by a super mode
it's a way for you to build applications
that are decentralized web three
applications on top of a set of apis
so those apis are there for you as an
application developer
um
apis that
allow you to connect to custom smart
contracts that use belts
and apis that let you do kind of
really quite complicated things
like
on chain off chain data coordination
broadcasting data to everybody in the
network that needs to be
put on a system like ipfs so it's shared
shared with everybody it doesn't fit on
the blockchain
sending data
securely directly from one member to
another member or to three different
members backed by the blockchain but
those that can't go on to the blockchain
because it's too sensitive or it needs
to be deleted so these flows
the sort of data exchange patterns
multi-party business process flows
apis that just do that there's a pattern
on top of those core core three
capabilities and then digital assets and
we you know anyone who's seen blockchain
knows just how important those digital
assets are to building use cases whether
it's uniqueness these nfts in an
enterprise context
knowing that everybody's referring to
the same thing in the world those nfts
or whether
it's
exchange a real value of value
digital settlement exchange of value in
a tokenized economy
um apis for that including all of that
plumbing that you need to build like the
off chain indexing
all built on sort of the the core of
fireflies an orchestration engine
kind of think about firefly is doing for
blockchain what something like
kubernetes does for docker
it sits low above um and
helps you orchestrate all of those
things together
so that's what it is at its core is this
orchestration engine
and um in the middle of it is an
event-driven programming model
i hope you find that that when he comes
through as you're using the sandbox
is everything in blockchain whether you
use firefly or not the only way to
program blockchain
is through an event-driven model so so
firefly helps you with that it makes it
easier for your applications that you
use things like web sockets
um to try and make it easier to build so
it's a platform for building on
and if we just look
at a more technical view rather than a
feature function viewer so the last
chart was the architecture this is the
architecture
um and look at the components of it
it sits
as a layer um
in parts generations of enterprise
software we've called this middleware it
sits between
the application
and all of those
core backend data systems
so whether that's public blockchain i
know there's questions about public drop
chain we're going to talk for a minute
about that
whether it's your own plugable private
blockchain you know whether it's
hyperledger fabric which we didn't see
today but
super simple to get started with just as
easy as with ethereum today um people
like jim zhang who's one of the tse
members um is key contributors to the
firefly community so
you know you can choose your new
enterprise version of blockchain that
we'll talk about
um uh about side chains as well but all
pluggables about these core sort of
um
blockchain native technologies but then
also
it sits on top of the sort of off chain
um data again pluggable things like
shared storage ipf as we talked about um
and then your own private data bus
because almost certainly if you're
building for enterprise there's going to
be data that's too
private to go onto the blockchain itself
so it sits as this layer in between and
it's a microservices architecture so the
reason why we're talking about how much
memory do i need well you first you need
docker and you need you know you need to
have all these containers running on
your laptop because it's designed to be
pluggable and nowadays plugable means
microservices it means a dockerized
kubernetes native
deployment model
um so so that's what it is um the way
it's constructed with no detail but no
time to talk about the detail of what
all of these different components are in
this session
and at its core it has a database a
private database
and this is this is something that's
really important
firefly is
stateful it has your private data
it's designed to sit at the boundary
between
your domain
and the blockchain where everybody else
is participating as well it's your view
of the world
the private data that you may be
exchanging with that network of
participants
and the blockchain data all indexed in a
fast off-chain database
so just wanted to make sure that
everyone was on the page of what it is
right now today
and let's talk about some of the the
roadmap items that we're working on
immediately coming out of v1
a bunch of these already started and in
flights um there's always room for
contribution new contributors so if
you're if you've got skills you want to
bring to the project
nico's um a great person to to to reach
out to to talk about how to get involved
um but all of these threads um are ones
that you can participate in but there's
also other threads that you could
work on as well
um if you are interested in contributing
key key focus areas one is um no
surprise being
an enterprise focused technology and
where enterprise adoption of
blockchain's been for the last few years
um firefly evolved and actually many of
the components have evolved over the
last four years of production
deployments on sidechains on enterprise
private blockchains
that are
secured with a sort of hard boundary you
have to be permissioned in you have to
be able to join the club to have access
to it technologies like hyperledger
fabric i pledge a betsu and even corda
um
nowadays the lines between what you
where
whether
a use case or whether use case needs
just a side chain or just public is
being blurred
it's really common to need a mix inside
of your inside of your business inside
of your projects
so we're seeing the
the the the lines of separation between
what used to be
you know obviously this is going to be
on the side chain and what used to be
well obviously this is going to be
public public those lines are blurring
um as more and more layer two and
another um sort of proliferation of
um
public blockchains and permission public
blockchains are happening
um
ck roll-ups and all these technologies
that are meaning that those things are
happening lots and lots more
and um
and as enterprises are thinking more
about digital assets
um uh business to consumer use cases so
so this is a big area that we've got a
big focus on at the moment there's
another focus around additional sample
applications that show things end to end
sandbox is so fantastic for seeing what
firefly does all the different
individual operations but what does an
end-to-end web 3 use case look like
sdks there's a node.js sdk hats off to
um to andrew
richardson who um who led the
development on that one um but
there's a goal to have sdk's for other
languages javascript et cetera um to be
for all the variety of application
development platforms that people work
in
um and and then sort of slightly beyond
that
i'm supporting talking to lots of
different blockchains
from a single firefly instance some of
this is available today you can actually
connect token connectors to token
economies and multiple blockchains today
on firefly but and that core sort of bus
where you're doing the um you're doing
the you know the smart the the custom
smart contracts etc
you're tied to one blockchain today so
that's that's a model that's going to
sort of evolve very quickly we think
um and then um another area there's a
big focus is on if this is your gateway
to the world and multiple blockchains
and there's multiple people that your
organization is connecting with in lots
of other different blockchains how do
you manage those connections
who am i connected to and what are those
identities that sort of how outbound
gateway security is is another area
and then uh some more features sort of
built in rather than just in the
kubernetes layer where they've been used
a lot of production deployments today um
uh actual pluggable api security um
extension extensibility in the pro api
as well
so that that's that's that i'm going to
just take one more minute before we just
open for um for
questions
and i'm just going to focus in on that
that public chain and i'm going to give
you a teaser of where that's going
so connect is inside of firefly to date
um we've had a connector for ethereum
called ethernet which is a very mature
technology um it's been involved over
the last four years we have similar um
solid um projects there for hyperledger
fabric and there's another um project
for chord apps um encoder which is you
need to customize a little bit more to
your core down
um
those are really focused on chains that
work really predictably they um
[Music]
they have enterprise-grade features
inside of them for streaming
transactions to a predictable blockchain
getting transactions there really
quickly
um but if they expect
those transactions to be really final
very quickly
um so once they're on the chain
you know you know that they're there
that's not the way most public
blockchains work most public blockchains
work it takes a lot of
time and effort and gas management and
resubmission and
um you know maybe you're going to need
to increase the value that you you've
given to the people to include your your
your transaction in their block um
public blockchains work in a slightly
different way so we have this evolved
architecture which has come along
specifically for public blockchains
i'm not going to go into detail here but
come along to the community sessions
which run on alternate wednesdays um to
learn more about this he's going to do a
deep dive on this in one of the upcoming
firefly community sessions but here's
here's the highlights
a new
quite significant component microservice
component inside the firefly called the
blockchain transaction manager this is
responsible for nonce management now
being pulled away from those connectors
and is responsible for things like
having a policy engine that can talk to
external gas station and make policy
based decisions on things like
resubmission
and look after your transactions for
minutes until they're made they make it
onto the blockchain
and things like the event streaming
which is traditionally the etherconnect
and fab connect has been all the way
down in the connector to the particular
blockchain and moving up into this
blockchain transaction manager so this
becomes the heavy lifter
and then the blockchain specific api
connectors and ethconnect now has the
first one of these there in the repo are
really easy
you've got a new blockchain
i want to just add support for the way
that it does
transaction submission the way it does
encoding
um i want to add that blockchain in
building one of those connectors is now
a very small job with this new
architecture because you don't need to
rebuild the heavy lifting ethernet and
fab connect both have all of that stuff
inside of that
so so this is a really significant
evolution of the architecture of the
firefly overall picture and this means
that plugging in
to tens
you know
increasingly we're seeing hundreds of
different blockchain ecosystems out
there
plugging your ecosystem into firefly
over the coming weeks and months is
going to get much easier and easier and
easier
so um i talked for a few more minutes
tonight that i hope to there thanks for
indulging me i hope that was useful
background and covering what we've done
and what's happening next i'll back to
you nico if you wanted just to do an
open open question session
thank you peter appreciate the the recap
and kind of the look ahead there it's
really exciting stuff and as peter said
you know if if this sounds exciting to
you and you you want to uh get involved
in the discussion about uh the future of
the project the you know in addition to
getting involved in chat and discord are
our every other week community calls are
a great place to
to have kind of the the deeper
discussion and and dialogue with
maintainers and other community members
all right so at this point we've got a
few minutes left i will open it up
um again please just there's quite a few
folks still on here over 100 people here
still which is super exciting uh so
let's just try to raise your hand if you
have a question or something you'd like
to chat about and i see mustafa has
their hand up so uh you have the floor
uh about the connector uh
we built that using javascript right
the connector that i showed today is
built using typescript and node.js yes
but there is
there's no restriction on what language
that has to be built in
okay oh
then i i don't get that this uh
connector like
it's being called using an api
using an http api that is or just an rpc
or something
exactly yeah there's a rest api between
the between firefly and the blockchain
connector yep
and it's
i also i didn't get that you
this connector is specific
to the
it can be specific to a blockchain or
can be specific to
a contract on the blockchain it can be
both right i choose
um it it probably should be both uh
because the the token connector is
uh the idea is that the
you will probably as as you customize
your smart contract you probably want to
customize the token connector that's
working with a specific contract to be
knowledgeable about uh the inner
workings of that particular contract
okay so
my connector
i'm right here
um just wanted to be really clear
there's two types of connector that
we've talked about
two completely separate ones
one is a blockchain connector
ethernet
fab connects
corda connect
that actually they were listening go
those connectors today the example ones
um and these connectors
will talk to any smart contracts
and in the demo and the walkthrough
you actually saw nico just teach firefly
about a new smart contract and that
could have been any smart contract in
the world as long as you can find this
information you can talk to it you can
listen to the events
then there's this separate connector
that nico was just talking about which
is written that the base ones the
examples
the sdk for writing these is in
typescript
you don't have to use typescript but
that's where the sample is
and these are tied to a particular
contract standard
and here we have an api that's specific
to tokens and firefly understands things
like what is a transfer what does it
mean what is the burn what is an
approval that you can then inside of
your connector you can tie it to your
particular token economy maybe you're
doing a security token with an erc 1400
standards and you need to sort of
customize to that that's why you might
actually need a connector for that
um
as well i hope that just extra bit of
information was okay there i know you
had a bit more to your question so uh
yes actually but i'm still a little
confused about the point that
are there like specific set of ercs for
example that are
uh can have those
contract specific connectors
like contract specific connectors
contact can be anything right so firefly
can work with
with any token contract
uh but the the particular token
connector in use should be designed to
work with whatever specific
token contract is deployed on chain
so it has for example uh
i should write an adapter for if i have
an arc 1155 for example exactly
that's the repo that peter's about to go
to right now so there's a different
token connector for erc 1155
okay and okay so most of the contract
specific connectors are focused on coins
or uh on tokens
yes token standards token standards okay
yeah yeah
and the reason is because for other
contracts that aren't
specific to tokens they might be doing
anything in the world right i've got a
i've got a bidding system um that you
know like a like a a long chain version
of an auction site right
that's going to be very bespoke to the
way that you've written that or a
lending library for books or you know or
a supply chain use case or like a
hundred different different things so
for those
you don't need a connector because
firefly will generate you an api just
like that
you just point by a flight at your smart
contract
but firefly
at that point it will allow you to
invoke every method on your smart
contracts and to listen
as long as it has
has a connector for such
networks
as long as
the blockchain technology is supported
yes
so if you're in an ethereum based um
blockchain technology then chances are
the support is is there or very close
even even if it's public maintenance
it's evm based you're in a good place
it's fabulous you're in a good place
with the connectors that are there today
um if some of the other um ones are
going to need extra connectors like a
solana connector all these sort of
things
but those are actually going to need a
war a war blockchain
connector i mean you know the existing
members of the community are expected to
be building some of those
and we expect as the community grows
those to be contributed by
by by those some of those those
blockchain technologies themselves
this way butterfly supports any smart
smart contract implementations but
because tokens are such a um
useful construct in the programming
model world we decided to make it a
first-class uh thing in car flight
programming model so
um specific token standards uh can be
supported uh as a first-class thing
uh so yeah the firefly ui can understand
specifically the workflow
of uh different types of
tokens
[Music]
thank you guys uh quick question david
do we have a hard stop at the bottom of
the hour or i
i'm free for some amount of time after
this like so you have the room as long
as you want okay great so
i i realize we're running out of time
here on the the official time uh on the
calendar but uh i'm happy if folks
have more questions i'm happy to take a
few more here
and if
if folks want to take questions to
discord we're also over there and we can
continue dialoguing hopefully even after
today as well
i think thanks good question and thank
you peter and jim for the detail on that
last one anybody else have questions
that they want to cover while we're all
together here today on the zoom
well if not i guess we can uh wrap up
right on time then
last call
uh if you have time and there's no other
questions i might as well hope there is
go ahead
uh so um i in my head i i have specific
use case for polkadot so
if i am to write
an adapter for a connector for polka
dots what i need is something that can
talk to
uh pocket.chain asked for
for uh
deployed contracts asks for the
abi like thing of those contracts and
converted to a standard format uh
read by the
firefly apis right
that's basically it
i think i think you've hit the nail on
the head there um
we'd love to continue this conversation
um uh the the polkadot power chains um
ecosystem is
is is high on the list um
and there's a but there's a lot of
active engineering just happening at the
moment
um on this new connect to architecture
um so if you're if you're literally
looking to like start coding within the
next five days
we should sing because i think you'll
find it's like there's components moving
about a lot
um um but i think in about a week's time
there's sort of like
instructions for like what
what's the recipe for a new connector in
about a week we should have that written
down
and that would be a great great place to
start
okay thank you
yeah mustafa uh ck had a similar
question like what about supporting
other
layer 1 public chains and i mentioned
any of the evm based
or any chain that supports evm and the
json rpc would be a really good
candidate for sort of the first wave of
new connectors because we already got
the the awesome youth connect that does
most of the evm based interactions
already so
a pair of chain on polka dot you know
like moonbeam for example uh avalon
unfortunately evm so yeah
great
but uh i was looking for others as well
or a custom uh power chain maybe
right yeah
it's definitely possible but it will
just take a slight a little bit more
work but definitely custom power chain
support is not a
um
would fit the firefly model we thought
about it along the way
so so i'm sure there will be a way to
fit it in it will just need a little bit
more because you'll have to think about
like you said the modeling of what does
the transaction look like
because you see an ability gives you
that for free um but we actually did
that for the fabric didn't we jim yeah
so i i think the fact that the
architecture supported fabric and
ethereum which is quite different uh
programming models and different uh
consensus uh designs it's a proof point
that we can support all kinds of
different uh blockchain layers on the
cover
i look forward to continuing this chat
on discord over the coming days and
weeks
all right well once again thank you
everyone for coming out today this was a
a great session i was just really
excited to see the turnout and the
participation and uh i've i've had a
chance to look over some of the chat
going on in discord and excited to
continue the conversation with folks
over there
thank you very much for coming out and i
hope you have a great rest of your day
thank you all
david do i need to do anything on my
side to shut down the stream here
you go are you done
yep we're wrapped up i'll shut it down
thanks everyone
thank you bye-bye